the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I'm determined to tell you something
about the convolution rule I just get
close to it but I haven't quite got
there and actually I'd like to say
something also about why convolution is
so important this I mentioned here a
paper about images in deep learning by
it has three authors and these are two
of them maybe you recognize Hinton's
name he's originally English he was in
in San Diego for quite a few years and
now he's in Canada so Toronto and
Montreal are big centers now for deep
learning son he's he's really one of the
one of the leaders and and so is skipper
so maybe you know that the sort of
progress of deep learning can often be
measured in these competitions that are
held like about every year for you know
how how well how well does something
people design and execute a whole neural
net and this was a competition about
images so that is really demanding
because as I said last time an image has
so many samples so many pixels that the
computational problem is enormous and
that's when you would go to
convolutional neural nets CNN because a
convolutional net takes fewer weights
because the same weight is appearing
along diagonals
it doesn't need a
full matrix of weights just one top row
of weights anyway so this is one of the
historical papers in the in the in the
history of deep learning I'll just read
a couple of sentences we trained so this
is the abstract we trained a deep a
large deep convolutional neural network
but I'll just enter say that they took
it ran for five days on two GPUs so it
was an enormous problem as we'll see so
we trained a large deep knit network CNN
to classify 1.2 million high-res images
in image net so image net is a source of
millions of images and on the test data
they well we the last sentences may be a
key we entered a variant of this model
in the competition 2012 competition and
we achieved a winning top 5 test error
rate of 15% compared to 26% for for the
second-place team so 15% error they got
26% was the best that the rest of the
world did and so so that and and when he
shows the network you realized what's
what's gone into it it has convolution
layers and it has some normal layers and
it has max pooling layers to cut the
dimension down a little bit and it's and
and half the samples go on one GPU and
half another and at certain points
layers interconnect between the two GPUs
and so to reduce overfitting you
remember that's the key problem is to
reduce overfitting in this in the fully
connected layers those are the ordinary
layers with
full weight matrices we employed a
recently developed regularization called
drop out so drop out as a tool which if
you're in this world you you I think
Hinton proposed it again by seeing that
it worked it's just a careful it's a
careful drop out of of some of the data
it reduces the amount of data and it
doesn't harm the the problem so so the
neural network has 60 million parameters
60 million with 650 thousand neurons
five convolutional layers and three
fully connected layers I just mentioned
this and you could if you just google
these two names you would on the web
view that paper this paper would come up
but it's so it's we're talking about the
real thing here convolution is something
everybody wants to understand and I I'd
like to since I've started several days
ago and I'd like to remember what
convolution means let me so if I
convolve two vectors and I look for the
case component of the answer the the
formula is I add up all the C's times DS
where the index i + j adds to k why do
you do such a thing
because c might be represented by a
polynomial say x + + c + X to the nth
and D might be represented by another
one D 1 X plus the M X to the M let's
say
and convolution arises when I multiply
those polynomials because for a typical
and then collect terms because a typical
power of X say X to the K the
coefficients are well how do we get X to
the K in multiplying these I multiply C
naught times a DK somewhere in here
would be a DK X to the K so a C naught
times a DK would give me an X to the K
term and a c1 times everybody sees this
coming now c1 has an X in it already so
over there we would look at DK minus 1
with one less X so it would be c1 DK
minus 1 this is just what you do when
you multiply polynomials and the point
is that the way we recognize those terms
is that the exponents 0 and K the
exponents 1 and K minus 1 always add to
K so that's where this formula comes
from we take a C times a D hiding behind
or a C X to the I and a DJ X to the J
and when a plus I plus J is K this is X
to the K and that's the term we're
capturing so this is the coefficient of
that term and let me write it in a
slightly different way where you
actually see even more clearly
convolution operating so J is K minus I
right so it's the sum of C I D J but the
J has to be K minus I so this is the
this is the way to remember the formula
for the
coefficients in the content C star D in
the convolution you look at C's times DS
it's it's a form of multiplication it
comes from ordinary multiplication of
polynomials and when you collect terms
you're collecting see the I C and the K
minus I D and you're taking all possible
eyes so it's just sum over all possible
eyes there to give you the case answer
well just to see if you got the idea
what would be the convolution of two
functions suppose I have a function f of
X and I want to convey the function G of
X okay and notice that I have not
circled this symbol so I'm not doing
periodic convolution I'm just doing
straightforward convolution so what are
we going to have in the case of two
functions what would that mean a
convolution of functions I'm I'm in
parallel here with a convolution of two
vectors so think of these now have
become functions the case component has
become really I should say F star G at X
that's really that's really the parallel
to this so let me so I'm I'm telling you
the answer at X here I told you the
answer at K case the case component
looks like that what does the x value of
the convolution look like for functions
okay I'm just going to do this I'm gonna
do the same as this instead of summing
what will I do integrate instead of C
sub I I'll have f of X
eyes the index I is changing over to the
continuous variable X and now G instead
of DK minus I what do I have here so so
it's uh it's K minus I component that
will go to let me just write it down t
minus X so so in this translation F is
being translated to C or sorry F is
corresponds to C G corresponds to D K
corresponds to X and oh sorry I
corresponds to X and J and K minus I
corresponds to t minus X so so K
corresponds to T that's this is what
would be the convolution of two
functions oh it's a function of T bad
bad notation to the T is sort of this
the amount of shift
you see I've shifted G I've reversed it
and flipped it and shifting it by
different amounts T it's it's what you
have in a filter it's just all of always
present in in in signal processing so
that would be a definition or I could if
you like I if you want an X variable to
come out let me make an X variable come
out by exchanging T and X so so this
would be X minus T DT I like that
actually a little better and it's the
integral over t minus infinity to
infinity if our functions were on the
whole line so that will there will be a
convolution rule for
the that this will connect to the
Fourier transform of the two functions
over here I'm connecting it to the
discrete Fourier transform of the two
functions and I've been making the
convolution cyclic so what does can I
add cyclic now this is ordinary
convolution this is what you had in the
first lab I think from from Raja Rao the
first lab you remember you had to figure
out what the how many components the
convolution would have and you didn't
make it cyclic so a cyclic convolution
if if this has n components and this has
n components then the convolution has n
components because you keeping yeah and
it's the key number there the length of
the period and similarly over here if F
is 2 pi periodic and G is 2 pi periodic
then we might want to do a periodic
convolution and bring it
get a get an answer that also has 2 pi
of period 2 pi yeah so you could compute
the convolution of sine X with cos x for
example
ok let's stick with vectors so so what's
the deal when I make when I make it
cyclic when I make it cyclic then in
this multiplication
I really should use I've introduced W as
that instead of exocyclic X becomes this
this number W which is either 2 pi over
n and has the property then that W to
the N is 1 so that all vectors of
greater than n can be folded back using
this rule to a vector of length n so we
get a cyclic job so how does how does
that change the answer well I only want
K going from 0 to n minus 1 in the
cyclic case I don't want infinitely many
components I've got to bring them back
again and let me just say what the rule
would be you just ask say I plus J you
would look at that modulo n that's what
a number theory person would call it we
only look at the remainder when we
divide by n so we so now the the sums go
only from 0 to n minus 1 and I only get
an answer from 0 to n minus 1 well I've
done that pretty quickly
that's if I wanted to do justice to so
is the the difference between non
periodic
so non-periodic and periodic will be the
difference between so I have some number
T zero on the diagonals t 1 t 2 t minus
1 t minus 2 and so on constant diagnosis
the key name there is triplets and if
it's periodic then I have I'll say C CC
and then the next one we see one C one
coming around to C 1 and C 2 coming
around so it's so as n by n period n so
it's a it's a circulant matrix n by n ok
that's just that's the big picture and I
think in that first lab you were doing
your rest to do the non circulant case
because that's the one where you have to
do a little patience what will be the
length yeah what would be the length of
a non-circular
so not circulant now suppose C suppose
the C vector has P components and the D
vector has Q components how many
components in there convolution so I
write that question down cuz I that
brings out the difference here yeah so
so if I have P if C has C has P
components
he has cue components then the
convolution of C and D has how many so
I'm multiplying so it's really this
corresponds to a polynomial of degree P
minus 1 right polynomials of degree P
minus 1 and this guy would be degree Q
minus 1 degree Q minus 1 and what I
multiply them what's the degree just ad
and how many coefficients well one more
I have to remember for that stupid zero
order term so this would have P plus Q
minus 1 component so that would have
been the number that you somehow had to
work out in in that first lab so that if
this had end components and this had n
this would have to n minus 1 it's just
what you would have like you say 3 plus
X times 1 plus 2x in this case P is 2 Q
is 2 2 components 2 components and if I
multiply those I get 3 X + 6 X is 7x + +
2 x squared and so I have 2 plus 2 minus
1 equals 3 components X constant X and x
squared yeah clear-rite
yep so that's not the that's what I
would get if I multiply these matrices
if I had a two diagonal matrix Triplets
matrix times a two diagonal Triplets
matrix that would give me a three
diagonal answer but if I am doing it
periodically I would only have to
that that 2x squared would come back if
if I come back as a 2 so I just have 5
plus 7x good right good good good
ok so that's a reminder of what
convolution is cyclic a non-sex like
vectors and functions okay then I can
values and eigen vectors or the next
step and then the convolution rule is
the last step so eigen vectors eigen
vectors of the circle of course I can
only do square matrices so I'm doing the
periodic case so the eigen vectors are
the columns of the of the eigenvector
matrix and I'm gonna call it f for
Fourier so f is the first eigen vector
is all ones an X eigen vector is the
fourth root of one then the square root
of one i 6 i ate i fourth i sixth and
finally one i cubed i 6i9 okay that's f
those are the four eigen vectors of the
permutation P and of any polynomial in P
so my circulant is is some C naught I
plus C 1 P plus C 2 P squared + c 3p q
okay and finally this is like the step
we've been almost ready to do but didn't
quite do what are the eigen vectors what
uh what eigenvectors are its
eigenvectors
so those are the eigenvectors of p and
now we have just a combination of peas
so I think the eigenvectors I just
multiply I take that same combination of
the of the eigen vectors yep yep is that
that look right so sorry
it's I'm sorry its eigenvectors they're
the columns of F the question I meant to
ask is what are its eigenvalues that's
the key question what are the what are
the eigenvalues and I think that if I
just multiply F times C I get the
eigenvalues of the matrix C that's the
beauty that's the nice formula if my
matrix is just P alone then this is 0 1
0 0 and I get 1 I I squared I cubed but
if C is some other combination of the
peas and I take the same combination of
the eigen vectors to to see yeah
do you see it so I'm claiming that I'll
get for eigen values of C from this
multiplication so of course if C know if
there's only C not then I only get C
naught C naught C naught C naught I get
it's a repeat four times repeated but if
it's a if it's this combination then
that matrix multiplication takes the
same combination of this is a
combination of
the eigenvectors and and that gives us
give it gives us the right thing okay so
that's now I just have one more step for
this the convolution rule and then I'm
happy really the convolution rule is
stating what we it's stating a relation
between multiplication which we saw here
and the convolution which we solve for
the coefficients so the convolution rule
is a connection between multiplying and
convolution and so let me say what that
convolution rule is and let me write it
correctly so so here I take cyclic
convolution I'm dealing with square
matrices everything is cyclic here and
then I get if I multiply by F what do I
have now
what does that represent this was C and
B and Ike involved them so I got another
circulant matrix so so so up here the
multiplication of of matrices is C times
D I want to connect multiplying those
matrices with convolving the C's I want
to connect make that connection right so
and that connection is the convolution
rule okay so this would be the
eigenvalues of CD
let's just pause there why why am I
looking at the eigenvalues of CD because
if I do that multiplication I get
another tipless matrix C times D and the
pollen only their coefficients
associated on the diagonals of C times D
are the coefficients of the convolution
so the its diagonals its diagonals come
from convolving C with D 6 - okay now I
want to find those same eigenvalues in a
second way and match and the equation
will be the convolution rule so how
could I find the eigenvalues of C D well
amazingly they are the eigenvalues of C
times the eigenvalues of D I'm gonna
test this rule on two-by-two so you'll
see everything happening but so this is
the main this is the fact that I want to
use because yeah because C and D commute
C and D commute they have the same eigen
vectors and then the eigen values just
multiply so I can multiply I can get
that in a second way by taking the eigen
values of C and multiplying those by the
eigen values of D and I multiply
component by component I multiply the
eigen value for the for the all one's
vector by the eigen value for the all
one's vector so I do a do you know this
MATLAB command component by component
multiplication this is it's an important
one there's a guy's name is also
associated with that so so that's a
vector that's a vector and what comes
out of that operation if I have a vector
with three components so n is three here
and I do point star or dot star I'm not
sure what people usually say component
by component a three component vector
times a three component vector I get a
three component vector just like that
yeah yeah so this is the convolution
rule that's the convolution and the
proof is the fact that eigen that when
matrices commute the eigen values of the
product or just these eigen values times
these eigen values because they have the
same eigen the eigen vectors are always
the same here for all these circulant so
there's the convolution rule that I can
convey then transform or I can transform
separately and then multiply so just
maybe better write that the convolution
let's call it the C rule convolve then
transform by F or transform separately
by F and then then multiply point wise
you know element by element yeah
component by some bonus okay yeah so
that's the convolution rule and why is
it sort of why is it so important
because transforming by F multiplying by
the Fourier matrix is extremely fast by
the FFT so so it's useful because of the
FFT the fast Fourier transform to
multiply yep or to transform whichever
multiplied by F transform
so it's it's the it's the exist presence
of the FFT that makes this it gives us a
really two different ways to do it
in fact which is the faster way so we
can produce the same result this way or
this way and if I don't count the cost
of if the cost of multiplying by F is
low because I have the FFT which would
you do
which would you do so let's let me just
think aloud before we answer that
question and then we're we're good so if
I so my vectors have n components so one
way I can do is to do convolution how
many how many steps is that if I take a
vector with n components and I convolve
with a vector with n components how many
little multiplications do I have to do
and square right because each of the C's
has to multiply each of the DS so that
takes N squared and Fourier is cheap
it's n log n log to base 2 so the
left-hand side is effectively in cubed
what about this one
how many up how many to do these two
guys to find the Fourier transform to
multiply by the matrix F ok those are
fast again that's just I've got two
multiplications by F so that's 2 n log N
and what's the cost of this
I have a vector with n components dot
star vector another vector with n
components how many little
multiplications do I have to do for a
Hadamard product or a or a component by
component product n only in + in yeah I
should maybe I should have made that +
yeah yeah I had I had to I know I had
one n log n plus it took M squared to
find that vector and then n log n so
it's effectively N squared but this one
where I do the N log n twice and then I
only it only takes me in more so this is
the fast way so if you wanted to
multiply two really big long integers as
you would want to do in in cryptography
if you had two long integers say of
length 125 126 128 128 components to
multiply those you would be better off
to separately take the cyclic transform
of each of those hundred and
twenty-eight guys and do it this way
take this take the transforms do the
component by component product and then
transform back to get that yeah yep so
it's the convolution rule is what makes
that go okay so that's oh one more
thought I guess about all this
convolution stuff suppose we're in 2d we
have to think what's what is a
two-dimensional convolution what does
this become
in two dimensions suppose we have
functions so now I'm to be functions of
x and y periodic or not periodic but
what will we what's a convolution what's
the operation we have to do in two
dimensions well it's a double integral
of course T and u we would do F of T and
u times G of X minus t y- u d TD u and
that would produce a function so i'm
convolving a function of x and y with
another function of X and again I'm
looking for the this this this is the
key to watch for x- t y- u that that's
the signal of a convolution integral
yeah so that that's what we would have
in 2d in generals do you so much may be
mine now my final thought is to move to
think about two dimensional matrices and
and their products and so on and this is
why you need them because you're you if
you're if you have two dimensional
signals then the components fit into a
matrix and we just have to operate in
both dimensions so so the the key
their key operation in 2d is in MATLAB
the MATLAB command that you need to know
to get if you know what you're doing in
1d and you want to do it in 2d the
MATLAB command is cron so so we imagine
we have one dimensional matrices a and B
and so those are in 1d and we want to
produce the natural to them
two-dimensional matrix so these will be
n by M and we want the sort of natural
product let me call it k for cron which
will be N squared by N squared I want to
create a 2d matrix with connected to an
image that's n in each direction so it
has it has N squared pixels this is
these are 1d signals and K is a 2d one
and this cave would be there this is the
operation to know given given to one
dimensional N by n matrices cron
produces a to an N squared by N squared
matrix
it's sick it's a operation to know so
I'll just write it in if you know what
cron is and you know what you know it
before I write it so what so I want to
produce a big matrix n squared by N
squared
somehow appropriately multiplying these
two guys and the appropriate way to do
it is to take a 1 1 and multiplied by B
so there what do I have what size have I
got they're already just in that one
corner n by n right it's a number times
an N by n matrix then a 1/2 times B
that's another n by n matrix up to a 1 n
times B so I have now sorry Kappa so I
have tap-in matrices in a row each of
those matrices is n by n so my that row
has length N squared and of course the
next row is I've I've allowed myself to
number from 1 to N but very often that
numbering should be 0 to n minus 1 and
finally going down here down to a and 1
B so so that's the N squared by N
squared matrix that you would need to
know for example if you wanted to do a
two dimensional transfer you transform
it would be yeah so what would a two
dimensional Fourier transform per do
what what matrix is this the matrix you
would use for for a 2d I haven't sort of
got started properly on 2d Fourier
transform so would it be F times F F
cronic so let me write down the full
name of this guy chroniker so it's
called the Kronecker product it's just
it's just the right thing to know in
moving from one dimension to two
dimensions for example let me
I got one board left yeah yeah so here's
a standard matrix call it a twos and
minus ones so that that's that chorus
that corresponds to a second derivative
or actually minus the second derivative
now suppose I have a mate another the
same matrix corresponding to second
derivatives in the Y direction same and
what I really want to do is both I want
to have a matrix K that corresponds to
minus the second in the X Direction
minus the second and the Y so this is
the Laplace laplacian which is all over
the place in differential equations at a
typical point I want to do - one of
these two of these - one of those in the
X direction and I want to add to that
minus one now that too becomes a four
and minus one in the Y direction so I'm
looking for the two by two mate
the the two dimensional matrix that
takes that does that five-point scheme
five weights for each point takes four
of the on the diagonal and minus one on
the four neighbors and the operation
that would do that would be you would
use cron it wouldn't be cron of a B that
would just K of a B is not what I what I
was a cron of a B is not what I want
yeah that would do one and then the
other one and then that would probably
produce nine non-zeros I want something
that adds here so I I want cron of a
time's the identity that gives me the
the two dimensional thing for this part
and then I'll add on cron of I be for
the vertical derivative the derivatives
in the Y direction so that would be so
that's called a chroniker some this is a
this is a the other was a chroniker
product so that would be a chronica
product this would be another Kronecker
product and that total is called the
chroniker some okay I wanted just to get
that those notations out because really
you know Fourier transforming I said is
such a central operation in in in all of
Applied mess and especially in signal
processing okay so I'm good for today
let's see I've got one volunteer so far
for to talk about a project can I
encourage an email from anybody it
doesn't you don't have to be a superstar
it's just willing to to do it tell us
something about what you've learned get
comments from the audience and you know
ten ten or fifteen minutes is all I'm
thinking about it yeah okay I'll let you
send me an email if you're if you'd like
to tell us that and get some feedback ok
good so I'll see you Wednesday
Thanks